hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen wir heute endlich mal wieder
zu einer neuen episode ebay felsen ich
würde sagen wir verlieren gar nicht
lange zeit und staaten direkt mit diesem
feld das ist ein einrad wurde
eingestellt für zehn euro in heidenheim
an der brenz im titel steht allerdings
ein reifen fahrrad
wer kennt ihn nicht den einen reifen
fahrer des kabinetts gecheckt beim
nächsten ebay verkauft eine person eine
nintendo switch sonderedition und zwar
die super mario all dies variante im
titel schreibt allerdings nintendo
switch sondern die roten mit 250 euro
du hast definitiv den vogel abgeschossen
warum sagt man eigentlich du hast den
vogel abgeschossen
das macht vorn und hinten sind was
allerdings auch keinen sinn macht ist
dieser ebay eintrag und zwar sehen die
schon hat jemand einen abort
reingestellt lkh verbot für 90 euro
christa haferflocken zum halben preis
für mit das ist der nächste iwf hält und
ihr seht schon im titel steht guter auto
mit guter motor brumm brumm aber
bisschen benutzt für 23 euro und da
denkt man sich jetzt vielleicht gut das
auto guter motor macht noch proben
proben bisschen benutzt okay kann er
nicht so viel mit sein na ja ist das
foto so sei auch das fahrschulauto nach
sanders erster fahrstunde aus zu kleiner
und das ist der nächste feld und zwar
seht ihr schon dass jemand einen
staubsauger der marke denn verkauft er
hat das allerdings falsch oben gelesen
und denkt die marke heisst urs und wenn
man das bild mal dreht beziehungsweise
das wort dreht was er meint dann kommt
da auch wirklich dyson bei raus auf so
was musst du wirklich erst mal kommen
hallo diese wohnung gefällt mir können
wir am donnerstag ein
besichtigungstermin machen uhrzeit ist
mir egal donnerstag ist fordert ak wenig
saufen wie jeder normale mensch zu
mensch jeder normale mensch
jeder läuft am vatertag jeder mensch
sollte am vatertag kann ich mir maul
halten ihr verkauft jemand zwei kostüme
auf ebay kleinanzeigen und zwar das
spiderman und schilddrüse kostüm beide
für 15 euro
wahnsinn ich wollte mich schon mal
schilddrüse verkleiden ist diese artikel
noch verfügbar noch verfügbar nein aber
danke und viel erfolg
und da frag ich mich einfach nur so hey
was ist die intention mancher leute mit
ihren nachrichten wenn übrigens das
nicht generell irgendwie gefühlt ein
bisschen neben der spur stehe und ihr
hört schon mal der nase sitzt zu meiner
augen sind ein bisschen rot ich habe
komplette pollenallergie ich bin uns
täglich zweimal zieht ihn zweimal
nasenspray augentropfen die ganze zeit
aber trotzdem sieht mein leben gerade
irgendwie ein bisschen mir vorbei ja
eigentlich sehe ich mal beschissen aus
in der tat allerdings hätte ich das
natürlich nicht davon ab den allerbesten
qualitativ hochwertigen content auf
youtube zu liefern und zwar machen wir
direkt weiter mit diesem ebay fällt das
ist ein interner dessen mario kart spiel
was jemand verkauft er schreibt
allerdings in die produktbeschreibung
spiel nintendo ds mafioso grad
das eigentlich dumm an der ganzen sache
beziehungsweise der eigentliche fehler
der ganzen sache ist allerdings dass er
das für 15 euro verkauft
bruder dafür kriegst du allerhöchsten 20
cent geld ist überwiesen ok super wenn
das geld drauf ist versende ich freu
mich schon auf ihre adresse des privat
[Musik]
kosten produkt auf ihn habe die adresse
der person zu gehen wurde du gekauft
hast du da bist du privat
[Musik]
trotz werbung für das kissen machen aber
es ist ausverkauft da wollte ich mich
auch mal ganz kurz bei euch für gedanken
meine liebe treue und zwar ist ja vor
zwei tagen dieses kiste luca shop
gelauncht das ist ein paar jetzt ein
kissen mit pailletten macht sinn
wir waren wieder extrem schnell die 2010
sind auf jeden fall alle schon weg die
werden jetzt die tage versendet und die
bekommt alle eine signierte
autogrammkarte also danke eigentlich
hatten wir von ersten sechsten jahr
wieder einen großen lounge geplant mit
ein paar t-shirts ein paar goodies und
auch mit diesem kissen allerdings der
korona kam dazwischen und wir
produzieren ja in italien und dann
hatten wir nicht die ganze muster phasen
deswegen haben jetzt gesagt kommen wir
verschieben das ganze und ich lounge
jetzt demnächst dann wieder einmal neue
produkte limitiert und so damit wir halt
unsere ideen noch verwirklichen können
aber darum sollte ich gehen soll und
nächsten ebay fell meine lieben freunde
und zwar seht ihr schon das ist ein
trauriger happy hippo wollte ihn essen
aber jetzt tut er mir aus irgendeinem
grund leid gebe ihnen deshalb ab 1 euro
dafür bekommst du fast eine komplette
packung happy hippos und diesem
glücklich mein interesse war sehr groß
und ich war bereit mehr zu zahlen aber
jetzt gucke ich mich anderweitig um
guten tag machen sie das liegt mir die
tischbeine wachsen lassen
du lachst nacken
kommentiert mal bitte unter diesem video
ähnliche beleidigungen und dann habe ich
ein bisschen kreativen input
wenn ich jemanden mal war allerdings sei
weiter mit dem nächsten liebe erfährt
und seht ihr schon dass so jemand einen
toaster verkauft er hat das allerdings
nicht ganz verstanden und sagt das ist
ein thorsten ich frage mich was bei
solchen leuten vorgeht die denken sich
dann ja ich gebe das mal ein und das
passt schon
ich brauche das einfach als als wenn
dann so wenig deutsch kann und was heißt
deutsch das ist ja sogar englisch aber
gut so typisch deutsches unternehmen die
welt uns war das hier guten tacho ich
hätte interesse an der us die voll
funktionsfähig und wann war der akku
wechsel san francisco hallöchen
mittelchen ja die uhr ist voll
funktionsfähig der akku wurde vor circa
einem halben monat getauscht auf
wiederhören
wer hat euch ins hirn geschissen cacau
das hier ist der nächste die bfl und ich
lasse ihn einfach mal unkommentiert
stehen
es ist eine julien schubkarre 98.000
euro habe ich nicht gesagt ich lass das
unkommentiert stehen machen wir das beim
nächsten ebay verkauft ich darf nicht
ich rede nicht schaut euch einfach an
[Musik]
was anders machen wir allerdings nach
dieser sanften einbildung nun auch
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten lieber
fällen zwar verkauft hat jemand die ady
das jetzt slide bau nimmt größe 43 was
ich mich dann einfach frage ist ist der
ebay fällt jetzt dieses jetzt sie weiß
wie sie eigentlich heißt oder weil
jemand schlappen für 75 euro verkauft
aber wer kauft denn so was ich trage die
schlappen hier und ich bin komplett
happy damit und die kosten nicht 75 euro
waren allerdings auch schon direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten liebe erfährt
und zwar seht ihr schon dass dort vier
brillen apps eingeblendet sind als
anzeigen photonen im titel dieses
angebot steht tausche vier brillenetuis
es fragt man sich natürlich gegen was
die antwort darauf findet man in der
beschreibung und zwar steht dort hallo
zusammen tauschen vier brillen der
tories gegen einen kleinen ofen käse von
rochat
ich habe auf meinen mikrofon gerotzt
nicht nur einmal dann bin ich ein
wasserfall alter welcher mensch denkt
sich ja ich habe gerade richtig bock auf
einen ofen käse for you get was auch
immer roulette ist so marke renault und
anstatt dann einfach im supermarkt zu
gehen oder sich irgendwas zu bestellen
online oder sony vielleicht will ja
jemand spontan vier brille tories haben
und vielleicht hat er auch spontanen
ofen käse zu hause
als klar alles klar bei diesen nächsten
ebay kleinanzeigen fällen fragt ein
verkäufer einen interessenten alle
zusammen 40 euro und der potenzielle
käufer antwortete daraufhin trottel
hallo du beliebige beleidigung einfügen
das ist eine normale frage und kein
grund unhöflich zu werden ich hoffe dir
fehlt bei der nächsten capri-sonne der
strohhalm stößt du deinen kleinen zeh an
der tischkante und ihr geht das
klopapier aus alles klar
einerseits der interessenten einfach
trottel schreibt auf seiner ganz normale
fragen oder noch der verkäufer der sich
aber die zeit im sonnen langen text zu
schreiben
hast du hast jetzt allerdings direkt der
nächste der kleinanzeigenteil und ihr
seht schon das ist ein flaschenöffner
auf kupfer da hier verkauft wird der
verkäufer stellt diesen flaschenöffner
allerdings als falschen opfer kupfer
rein und hat ganz oder für 15 euro
warum kauft man sich einen
flaschenöffner für 15 euro dafür kriegst
du schon die ganze kiste bier die gabel
auf machen willst kann ich mir das
angucken fragt ein interessent und der
verkäufer antwortet ja hab aber keine
nummernschild schade kann ich jetzt
kommen
ich komme jetzt nein hdf ich komme jetzt
läuft falsch
bei diesen ganzen leuten auf ebay
kleinanzeigen hättet ihr bock darauf
dass ich mir selber auch mal die bei
kleinanzeigen account mache und auch mal
so ein bisschen leute da einfach tolle
oder trolle oder wie auch immer man es
nennen mag ich hätte auf jeden fall mega
top drauf ist natürlich dann bis den
arbeit mit dem account und dann hier
auch die ganzen leute anschreiben und
angebote finden vielleicht sind die auch
dann nicht so lustig unterwegs und
zeigen mich an
aber lasst man like da und bei 14.000
auf jeden fall dem nächsten angriff
nehmen allerdings machen wir direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten werk
kleinanzeigen fällt ihr seht schon das
ist ein kühlschrank und er wird im titel
auch als kühlschrank für 30 euro
beschrieben und in der beschreibung
steht allerdings es funktioniert aber
kühlt nicht mehr ja bruder das genauso
wie du sagst ich verkaufe mein auto
fährt aber nicht
ich verkaufe mein hamster der lebt ab
ja okay das war ein gemeines beispiel
aber ihr wisst was ich meine und das
macht vorn und hinten kann sind hier
verkauft dir dein iphone 664 durch
arbeit und ich blende euch hier mal den
verhandlungsverlauf 1
es ist wirklich es ist wahnsinn aber die
haben sich am ende
am ende haben sie sich geeinigt auf
einen preis von 60 euro und kommen wir
nun allerdings auch schon zu den letzten
beiden ebay fails fürs heutige video und
zwar sind es ja mal wieder die reime
numero uno ist ich fahre ihn in urlaub
und überlege wo ich die sachen rheinpark
ein glück habe ich noch jack wolfskin
rucksack hat sich jetzt nicht so mega
krass gereimt rheinpark rucksack mainz
jetzt nicht so richtig allerdings habe
dafür noch diesen hier rose sind rot
mein freund hat mir meinen arm
verstaucht für meine rache wir daher
einen tennisschläger gebraucht steht ihr
weil ihr freund heißt denis an der
stelle mich dass heute wieder ist
allerdings ob ende meiner lieben freunde
wenn euch die heutige wieso die bfl zwar
wieder gefallen hat dann zeigt mir gern
mit einer bewertung unter dem heutigen
video worunter auch sonst was daumen
hoch da abonniert main kanal
falls sie noch kein teil der lupus
kostenlos und über 70 prozent der leute
die das hier gerade schauen sind kein
argument von meinem kanal also wer
entspannt wenn es auch so bleiben würde
allerdings könnt ihr einen kanal auch
ganz easy abonnieren in dem ich hier
oben einfach auf den smiley darauf trägt
wie bereits gesagt jetzt ist kostenlos
und verpasst keine videos mehr und wenn
ihr schon so leicht wird genau wenn ihr
schon abonnent sein sollte dann klickt
auf die glocke denn dann bekommt den
benachrichtigungen ich hab's hochladen
zum beispiel dass hier ein anderes video
hier verlinkt
[Musik]